all right so welcome everybody again
this is chess for Knights
this is a class where I'm gonna teach
you one brilliant sacrifice the
so-called Greek gift
[Music]
so why plate efore and black plate a6
you know how this defend it's called the
French defense exactly okay
c5 you know how this is called Sicilian
Sicilian one of the most aggressive
openings that you can play right
Magnus cousing has played it six times
in the World Championship
okay against Fabiano Caruana you you all
know Fabiano Caruana yeah yes he lives
here he he is from the club yeah so it's
so great to have a world champion in
your own City
yeah so I am from Spain there was never
any Spanish champion so okay so he
played a six and then D for controlling
the center right this is so important
and now white black played nine f6 this
is not a very good move but four hundred
years ago they didn't know much theory
right they didn't know much openings
they didn't have databases to search for
games or or stockfish yeah you'll know
what is stockfish no it's the best
engine you can use
so now professional chess players they
use engines to prepare their games and
actually every for example you can
download an app in your cell phone which
is stronger than the world champion okay
but 400 years ago they didn't have
smartphones right or stock pitch exactly
or iPads yeah or TVs exactly yeah
exactly
okay so black plate 9 f6 I'm now Bishop
d3
a normal move right trying to develop a
minor
peace and then protecting efore right
because efore was attacked
so 96 was played attacking d4
what would you play here to defend d4
yes yeah
not a very perfect you develop a minor
piece you protect d4 yeah and now you
are ready to castle right Bishop e7 and
now these players in the 16th century
were really aggressive players so they
were thinking all the time about
attacking the opposite King so that's
why Greco played h4 yes really
aggressive move and black played sure
Castle which is a bad move what would
you play here with white
how would you gain some space in the
center by attacking some pieces so what
are your candidate moves would you play
d5 why why why why because black can
take it right he fight it's interesting
or not ok if I was played a brilliant
move and now Knight d5 and here we come
to the first important moment where I'm
gonna explain you what is the Greek gift
the Greek gift is a sacrifice to do on 8
7 but you have to fulfil some necessary
conditions to be successful so I'm going
to tell you the necessary conditions for
this sacrifice to work and the first is
that you should have a bishop pointing
are not 8 7
be ready to be sacrifice ok the second
condition is that you should have a
knight that can jump to g5 after the
sacrifice given a check third condition
can anybody tell me
the third condition yes
perfect you the Queen has to be able to
get to the age file so you have a clean
here ready to get to the age file okay
something else
black shouldn't have a night able to
come to f6 after the sacrifice in proper
conditions okay so for example here in
this position black could jump later to
f6 but you have upon stopping that all
right and then the fourth condition no
this is this was already the fourth yeah
so the fifth condition is black
shouldn't have a queen or a bishop able
to reach this diagonal be one eight
seven this is really important now we're
going to see some examples like that
this position will fulfill all the
requirements and white can capture an 8
7
boom Bishop 8 7 King takes 8 7 and now
what would you play with the white
pieces Knight g5 right check the thing
is if black goes back to g8 now how do
you finish up on it yes
perfect yet you bring the Queen to h5
and now what are you threatening here
with the white pieces checkmate in one
move
how come black stop it he can't are you
sure
I mean he can try yeah he can try for
example with two moves the first move is
Bishop takes a g5 and the second move is
rukia a black plays rook e8 checkmate in
two moves yes
yeah I'm then after King f8 perfect
brilliant
so queen 817 f8 Queen H a right black to
try another option so black to try to
take on g5 in this position Bishop takes
g5 and now it's a really important
moment you have to decide my microphone
you have to decide how to take now with
the eight pawn or with the bishop are
you sure
what bishop who would take with the
bishop you would take with the bishop
you okay
it's really important to open the H file
so how do we open the H file yes
exactly brilliant because now we are
again threatening checkmate on h8 right
because this rook is contributing for
this right how would you try to stop
checkmate now with the black pieces
f6f-5 g6 yes
[Music]
part of 60.5 and now the last move to
finish your opponent where he can't stop
checkmate yes j6 perfect now there's no
disk where this F 7 squared to run away
with for the black in and now Queen H it
is just unstoppable right so for example
takes sorry Shinji 8 and then Queen h5
Bishop takes and g6 if the if the rook
goes to e8 right then Queen h8 checkmate
right so there's no way black can't run
alright so in the game white played 95
and black took straightaway on g5 again
Queen 85 or H takes g5 check and if
black goes back to G 8 then what will
you play Queen age 5 and then we are
transposing to the line that we just saw
right in the game black try to skate by
a g6 and now what should we do here okay
so check on h5 holy move Tina 5 and then
there is a checkmate in 1 2 3 moves
I'm gonna put it like this how how do
you finish your opponent look at the
skin on f5 yeah it's terrible placed
so anybody can see checkmate in three
moves you see okay tell me
okay okay so anybody else
Luke eight free that's probably a good
move as well I'm gonna try to escape I'm
gonna try to play hmm let's say Knight
takes d4 and now you want it to give
check on a three right now this Knight
controls f3
okay checkmate in three moves check
check and check me that's a solution who
sees it
yes g6 check alright how about if I just
go King to e4
every check be careful
I'm running away kindiy for and then I
want to go to c5 and b6 right so yes yes
pawn g4 check are now keaney for only
move right and now not that easy right
incredibly this skin escaping okay so g4
is not the move yes Queen afraid the
thing is I go back to j6 and then after
Queenie for I can just play f5 okay yes
one more one more chance here yeah yeah
and then if I just take here on d4 c-3po
c2 upon the bishop
III but then I can just capture right
okay this is the solution Queen eight
seven g6 and now two more moves after g6
whoa what you want to play now checkmate
in two moves think think
okay yes g4 and how about kini for now
you have to give me checkmating one move
because it was checkmate in two moves so
let's try to think a little bit yes ruk
eight five here but then I can just take
for example right so queen eight three
perfect enough the kini for checkmating
one yes okay Queenie three don't blunder
your queen
Knight c3 I can't just take just
checkmating one in one f3 King takes d4
it's not the move it's so what's the
move what's the move it's very easy but
was about 24 no I have not afford Queen
f3 now I have King sexy 492 I can take
on d4 it's not the move Queen d3 perfect
awesome you see it's really important to
think before playing yeah automatically
you said like 10 10 moves that it was
not checkmate Queen f3 no pawn pawn no
no there's king before so we said that
the move was
queen d3 right so you can't take right
because he's protected you can't take
for the same reason you can take because
of the same reason there's no Queen f4
because the bishop is controlling the
square no Bishop f5 because the green is
controlling the square no kini a3 not
tv3
so that means checkmate sorry and okay
I'm gonna show you another example and
then after this we start playing some
games right yes last example this game
this game corresponds to one game in the
Spanish championship last summer so
black played Bishop takes d5 and now you
can see that is a similar type of
position right we have to see if
sacrificing on 87 if the Greek gift
works in this position to remember the
necessary conditions so tell me let's
let's count the the five necessary
condition the first one you have to have
a bishop able to sacrifice on 87 we have
that right we have a bishop that can
come to 87 what else
a knight that can go to g5 a queen that
can go to the h5 three conditions but we
cannot forget their conditions that
refer to the black player two conditions
that refer to the black layer a knight
can come to f6 so there is no night
right so we fulfill the fourth condition
but do you remember the fifth condition
this is the hardest one
exactly
and what happens here are you sure there
is a bishop
look at this bishop on b5 this bishop
can't end up in the B 187 diagonal yes
right how ya going to d3 but okay it's
White's move so Bishop 87 King takes 8 7
Knight to g5 King to g8 and finally what
we want to play here yes Queen h5 do you
think white is winning yeah no so what
will you play here to prevent checkmate
on 87 yes back there yes you Bishop d3
that's a brilliant move and actually
black is winning this game and this is a
game between two international masters
yeah two international masters in the
Spanish championship the white player
didn't take in account the fifth
condition yep the fifth necessary
condition and he blundered and now black
group wins after Bishop d3 because you
control this very important square on
870 so one last example okay and then in
two minutes and then we play some games
for example this game between Kasparov
and Nigel short you know you all know
Kasparov right
he even played he played hearing the San
Luis chess club several times right some
okay let's check this position again
this is the position and black played
Bishop b4 this is a really tough example
so let's see if we fulfill their
requirements the necessary conditions
Bishop can land an eight seven one night
can come to g5 to the Queen can come to
the eight file not really
that's why this example is sawed off
because it actually works but we have to
see why there's no night and that can
come to f6 right
there's no bishop or queen that can end
up in the b1 $87 right but you're going
to see how this example works so Bishop
8 7 King takes 8 7 night yeah there's a
rockin see 3 Knight g5 check King g8 and
now what's the best move here yes Luke 8
3 what's the threat what's white Fred if
black plays for example Bishop 8 6 here
in this position
yeah for example somebody else somebody
else yes
you ruk h8 beautiful combination from
garry kasparov ruk h8 kim taek's h8 and
now i want you to for example you with a
blue jacket
what's your name down there no don't
look behind you what's your name David
tell me how do you finish black saponin
think that magnus carlsen is playing
against you and you have the opportunity
to beat him in two moves check this out
how do you finish magnus carlsen no no
come on here come on here Queen eight
work
Queen eight three perfect and now after
King GA after King g8 what would you
play exactly awesome
this is the gear if the the cricket just
remember okay five necessary conditions
even a lot of top players they don't
count them and then they blundering in
in tournament games
so just remember them when you have a
position like this try to count all of
them Bishop can come to 87 Knight can
come to h2 g5 a queen or a rock or a
heavy piece can come to h-file no knife
coming to f6 no bishop or Queen coming
to the b1 $87 okay let's play some games
yeah
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]